how can i keep my daughter nine years
old away from these dangers from the
internet only two things one
you actually don't let her spend time on
it
which as you know is very hard because
everybody in her world will be on it
two and this is the most important
i have a 13 year old daughter and i
think about this a lot this is my number
one thing that i'm most passionate about
period in the end the world number one
way to protect the child
is to build their self-esteem
when a child is not insecure
they don't succumb to danger make sure
she's confident about who she is isn't
overly reliant on how she looks build
her actual self-esteem because you're
not going to be able to watch her every
minute no i can't but but if you make it
i know you do which is why i'm telling
you this i can sense that you realize it
if you make her confident in who she is
that she's amazing the way she is she
will not succumb to other people
and that is how she will navigate thank
you very much